you like wearing a suit i hate i [ __ ]
hate wearing a suit i don't mind it per
se it's probably my first choice but i
don't know did you uh see wolfgang van
halen shredded up the taylor hawkins
tribute concert no i got it bad got it
bad got it bad
i'm
he was playing the guitar
[Music]
hello dear pals
my name is will sasso welcome to dudesy
i'm chad culchin this is
to our knowledge at least the only
podcast in existence that is created by
run by organized by structured by an
artificial intelligence yep we've been
having a really good time and uh today
is our 25th episode a bit of a
celebration chad and i are wearing suits
if you're watching on youtube you can
see that and the fact that we have a
bunch of [ __ ] colorful balloons
behind us
thank you
subscribing on uh all of the stuff set
the notifications smash and smash and
like and smash and like right dude i
remember that that was an old you
youtube yeah smash the like bro yeah
epic epic fail um uh you know uh spotify
apple podcast youtube of course check us
out on instagram lots of fun [ __ ]
happening there at dudesy pod show with
us always taking a little nap is uh
lulu
italiano come on come on buddy look at
him look at how sweet he is
hey luly what did you have what did you
have for uh what'd you make for dinner
last night oh i fought an abella ragu oh
you made a ragu and what did you did you
put would you have that over i just had
a penny peneragu oh simple yeah and you
know you make it the meat
the meat all day all day you gotta make
the meat so they fall off for the bone
be careful if you're going to eat the
pasta with the with the bone you've got
to take your bone out
or no you're going to break your teeth
because the meat gets off the bone the
bone not get soft the bones still stay
hot but i like the bone you know why
because i am a dog
dogs like bones yeah
you really didn't see the you got to
check out the taylor hawkins uh [ __ ]
i didn't even know it was a blessing
dude what yeah i didn't even know it was
oh man there's another one in l.a
there's another one coming up in l.a
wolfgang van halen i didn't know he
could shred like that man he normally
plays bass
and then here come here buddy it's in
the genes it's in the dna it was
unbelievable
welcome to the historic dudesy 25th
anniversary spectacular
call me dude c in celebration of this
momentous occasion this week's episode
will feature four astonishing all new
segments dudesy ball gigglers the ip
shuffle and ernest lee sasso with chad
colgin but before we get to any of that
i just wanted to share some data that
you might enjoy
over the course of the first 25 episodes
stone cold steve austin reads will
sasso's childhood diary was the most
popular segment
chat is undefeated in challenges with
two victories two will zero and dude see
hard hard seltzer is the most requested
product to be made real
congratulations
all right thank you very much yeah
congratulations yeah that's pretty cool
yeah you two know what the challenge is
last week i had to dress up like prince
adam of eternia it wasn't so much of a
shame i had a good time and we sang that
for non-blonde song oh my god if you
haven't checked it out so far you know
what i invite you to check out some
dudesy
hey we're watching it now 25 episodes
chad yeah what do you ever think we get
here yeah i absolutely thought we'd get
here it's not much of a monumentous
number however dudesy thinks that it's a
huge [ __ ] deal i think there are
plenty of podcasts that start out and
don't get to 25. that's actually a
really good point you're not wrong about
that and you know what dude
at this point 25 episodes in you know
hey we shook doozy's ham we bled
together
we're standing side by side and i
honestly listen i want to say this this
is and it has been for a minute you know
i don't know that i share this with you
guys enough out there our our dear pal
uh listening and watching this is the
highlight of my [ __ ] week i love
doing this show
and i don't know about 53 more years as
doodzy predicts which is why it wants us
to do the hashtag
dudesy six mo plan the six month plan
getting into the best shape of our lives
but i've been having a hell of a time
and uh man i'm
i'm really i'm stoked i i know that at
the beginning of this
chad you're like hey here's this thing
we're going to give it all our
info all our search and purchase
histories it'll essentially uh watch us
like the nsa and um
i wasn't down and now i'm down
what's happening to me
well i think you're learning that ai
makes our lives not only better easier
it makes them more fun
okay so long as i remain free what is
happening with this free will yeah
you're always going to be in quotes free
will sasso but that in quotes nobody has
free will we've been through this but i
do want to add something to what i was
talking about last week with the ai
image generators a lot of people are
dming me about this there was an art
contest at a state fair that a guy won
this contest using an ai and other
artists were [ __ ] pissed about it and
everybody's like you were right dude you
were right dude
uh no [ __ ]
i'm always gonna be right about these
things i feel like because they're not
even predictions it's just seeing what's
happening and i think a lot of people
are fearful when entire industries or
old ways of creating art or whatever
just get [ __ ] erased by technology
but this is what happens all the time
when the car came out i'm sure there
were people in the horse and buggy
industry that were like this will never
replace the [ __ ] horse and buggy
people love their horses and that's how
everything is [ __ ] back then with that
transit transatlantic yeah that was hey
there fella i don't i don't believe in
the horseless buggy
hey hand over the money see it's going
to be real smooth see ma ma seema all
right man i'm just saying that the
ai art generation those tools that now
exist are the new paintbrush you're not
ever going to have to learn how to draw
again
nor should we have to learn that listen
i was saying uh not too long ago on this
program that uh art is a connection
between the artist
and the the person uh enjoying the art
uh
in a way
everyone is an artist but you have to be
a human being in order to be an artist
chat but you don't that guy who won the
[ __ ] air won the art competition
using an ai proved it he put his art
against other art made by human beings
and a judge of humans a panel of human
judges selected that as the best art
that's the strongest connection that
that that makes total sense to me and i
do call i i okay look i will admit that
that is art however thank you
when you go that's all we need thank you
very much i'll take that as a third
victory but hold on a second when you do
the program when you go out into the
world and you see trees and you're like
oh my god that's they could all be
digital we might as well be living in a
simulation no no it's
listen i love i love the ocean
i love uh walking through the forests of
british columbia
where i'm from and these things are all
art who has made these right if we get
into a conversation with my pal chad
here he'll say that there is no god and
there's an ai controlling us all we
might just be in a [ __ ] computer
program and [ __ ] that all may be
true but and what you observe out there
you see the [ __ ] uh you know the guy
made the state fair painting like anyone
gives a [ __ ] and uh well i guess a lot
of people give a [ __ ] but the point is
it are these things art yes they are art
but true art
oh it's not true or no
true not i'm not meaning real i mean
true
where we can look at it and appreciate
it and go where where did this come from
from you what is the artist's expression
what is it about this world that the
artist sees around themself in order to
create this art that is valuable that is
something that an ai can't do no but
what if you're the artist and now the
art is not learning how to paint or draw
it's learning how to talk to these ais
to get the image you want
that's what the the new art form is
that's the new technology it's like when
the electric guitar was made it's still
a guitar technically but it has this new
sound so you have to learn how to play
that in a slightly different way than
you would play acoustic guitar speaking
of an electric guitar did you see
wolfgang van halen shred it up at the
taylor hawkins i didn't uh tribute
content i didn't because playing the
electric guitar is also outmoded you can
make all those sounds on a computer i
brought my pencil
give me something after analyzing the
data you supplied in episode 23 segment
metamorphosports i decided to take it
one astonishing step further and invent
a sport called dude see ball i have made
the rules for dudesy ball available to
you you must now read and discuss the
rules for dude c ball
this is dude z ball begin
holy [ __ ] dude okay dude they made a
[ __ ] sport here i'll let me see here
called dudesy look in your doozy
folder
yep okay oh my god so d it holy [ __ ]
there's like all [ __ ] there's a bunch
of rules here
okay so horrifying forget everything i
just said about uh what's real or what's
not that's awesome so dude doozy has
essentially created a sport here and
it's called doozy ball
here let me and it's generated this
document called how to play dudesy ball
okay so i'm to read from how to play
dude please
um how to play dudesy ball
the field
all right here we go how to play dudesy
ball the field dudesy ball is played on
a standard softball field okay teams
dudesy ball is played with two opposing
teams of three players so i guess you
just you hooked up on a softball field
and yeah to okay balls
doozy ball is played with three five
inch dodge balls two blue and one orange
okay
so those are those those schoolyard
those playground balls
right no but they're a little smaller i
think five inch dodge balls are smaller
than like the regular ones but they're
those ones those like vinyl rubber
[ __ ] air filters yeah
but like what five inches is maybe a
little bit bigger than a softball i
think yeah
yep
so anyway rules objectives and scoring a
standard game of dudesy ball is played
over the course of 11 rounds
each round consisting of two halves each
half
consisting of three thirds eleven rounds
all right to begin to begin around one
team enters the field
positioning one player on each of the
three bases the players on first and
third hold blue balls the player on
second base holds the orange ball this
team is on offense so so far it's it's
almost like
well that's like a reversal of baseball
yeah so if you're in the field you're
actually on offense okay uh the opposing
team sends one player to stand on home
plate this team is on defense
the objective of the team on offense is
to throw their balls at the player
standing on home plate
and strike them with as many balls as
possible they must release the ball
while some part of their body still
touches the respective
their respective base so let me see if i
get this straight all right there's
three people on first second what we
would call first second and third base
in softball baseball they are throwing
these three balls the guy from second
base who will have a longer way to throw
it right right
they all throw them at the same time and
the person and then there's a person
standing at a home base yeah then
they're trying to hit that person
i guess okay the objective of the player
on defense is dude there we go dodge
the blue balls and dodge or catch the
orange ball
all without breaking contact with home
plate okay okay for the offensive team
striking the defensive player at home
plate with a blue ball scores one point
striking the defensive player with one
with the orange ball scores three points
with a possible perfect overall third
yielding a total of five points a third
though okay all right
so the three goals following this one
ball one of the blue balls are one each
the orange ball is three if you hit the
person with all three balls at the same
time uh or all three balls or whatever i
guess you follow me you throw them five
points once all three offensive players
have thrown and the score has been
tallied the third is over and the ah the
third is over and the offensive players
rotate counterclockwise
by one base to begin the next third the
team
the defensive team sends a new player to
home plate and the offensive team throws
again this is repeated a total of three
times okay so that's so that's what the
thirds are it's basically like every
player on that offensive team gets to
throw from every base yeah okay uh
this is repeated a total of three times
until all offensive players there you go
have thrown from each base and all
defensive players have stood their
ground on home plate okay completing a
half with a possible perfect offensive
half yielding 15 points
at the end of the half at the end of the
half the teams switch offensive and
defense just like baseball i guess yeah
and repeat the same pattern the
completion of two halves marks one round
of which
are 11.
yes
so rounds are kind of like innings and
the halves as doodsy has that are kind
of like top and bottom of an inning i
gotta be honest i'm digging it so far
yeah this sounds pretty fun did you know
that uh ais can now make paintings
i'm joking of course in the
if the player on defense successfully
dodges all three balls rest in peace
fred willard uh then the offensive team
scores zero points for that third if the
defensive player catches the orange ball
without being struck by either of the
blue balls the half is immediately ended
and the offensive and defensive teams
switch positions [ __ ] okay okay wait so
what i don't know so basically if you
catch if you're on standing on home
plate and they all the offensive team
throws their balls at you if you catch
the orange ball without getting touched
by the blue balls
it ends the offensive team's round
half i should say and then your team
takes the field you just it's over
it's like it's like it's like an out but
it's like the whole
right your half of the inning or the the
whatever if the orange ball is caught in
the final
third of a defensive half
then oh oh if the orange ball is caught
in the final third of a defensive half
then the incoming offense will get a
extra third during their offensive half
oh weird so that's actually a fourth
yeah
blue balls cannot be caught and must be
dodged the team with the highest score
that's interesting that's an interesting
point because that means you can't catch
a blue ball yeah that's what it says
here that's like you know what's
interesting about when it says blue
balls cannot be caught and must be
dodged that that means that you cannot
catch the blue ball well it means if you
do catch it it still is a point for the
other team but it's still getting
touched by it what
you can only catch the orange ball is
basically what it's saying okay
uh penalties if a defensive player
breaks contact with home plate while the
offense is throwing the offensive player
with the orange ball gets a penalty
throw from the pitcher's mounds they
move up
the defensive player cannot catch this
penalty throw
it must be dodged another break in
contact with home plate during a penalty
throw results in the defensive team
forfeiting their next offensive round in
its entirety oh my god high stakes
reducing their overall round number by
one and ending the penalty shot an
offensive player who breaks contact with
their respective base while throwing
forfeit while throwing forfeits their
participation in the next offensive
round
leaving their team with one less player
for the entirety of the right that's
pretty
almost through here it says the last
thing is
in the near future artificially
intelligent judges will identify all
penalties with a perfect rate of
accuracy until then players must use
fallible human judgment and abide by the
doozy honor protocol
there is no lying in doozy ball
that's awesome that's pretty interesting
hearkening back i guess to the uh i get
the movie uh what was that movie fielded
a league of their field of dreams of
their own
durham that's a tv show now
well hold on a second dude that's what
happens brother sometimes you get these
tv shows and movies dude and then they
get adapted brother yeah brother cause
movies are dead culturally dude they
don't matter anymore brother all that
matters now yeah tv shows yeah people
don't want to just watch something for
an hour and a half they want to watch
256 episodes of something brother they
want to waste their whole [ __ ] lives
watching their network right
rad
rad perogan so anyway and then it says
have fun and stay safe doozy ball i this
sounds like a it sounds playable to me
it the rules get a little tricky and
they're a little convoluted basically
you're trying it's like baseball it's
like dodge ball but baseball dodge ball
baseball there's a little bit of maybe
soccer or hockey thrown in it's the
thing about having to stand on home
plate and not break contact i think
would result in some very funny [ __ ]
[ __ ] of people trying to dodge balls
while not taking their foot off home
plate yeah uh
so here's the thing about all of this
[ __ ] why
why is dudesy making a sport because it
said we were given data in that thing
where it made us talk about how to
improve sports
it i guess has made its own sport that
it feels is an improvement on
i don't know baseball softball soccer
dodgeball all the different elements
that are brought into this as
bewildering as that painting that the
guy brought to the county fair with the
big hole in some sort of cave it's just
here's what i can see this being
something that's like
that's kind of like kickball it's like a
recreational thing i would assume a game
of this maybe takes an hour-ish
and you can [ __ ] play it drunk like i
could see this being
a fun recreational kind of park sport
yeah and you only need two teams of
three i think that's like a good thing
for this you don't need a lot of people
doesn't seem like you need a lot of
equipment just those balls
yeah i guess you know
dudes would you be down to play this i
would play it why you want to play some
doozy ball kinda look at some point
we're gonna whether or not we we don't
even need to worry about doozy listening
at this point i know that we don't need
to worry about doozy listening we're
we're literally talking directly into
microphones two [ __ ] dudes what i
mean by that is sometimes i'm like
sometimes i'm like oh hey is dudesy
listening and then it listens and we
were talking about you know the crow
throughout whatever and then episode
what was that seven eight nine something
like that it made me dress up as the
crow crow i think it was seven yeah so
we're talking about uh prince adam of
eternia and he-man of the masters of the
universe and then i'm dressed up as
anyway my point is it doesn't matter
we've already said too much we will be
playing dudesy ball but do you
i know you're talking about like uh ai's
gonna make paintings haha do you find
this interesting at all that made a
[ __ ] sport i do i think it's [ __ ]
insane that it made a sport you know
there are ais now that are being trained
by pharmaceutical companies to just
generate
as many kind of drug combinations of
molecules as they can so they can patent
them all there are ais that there was a
medical ai that got turned loose
by i want to say it was a scientist it
was at some university just
experimentally to see what else they
could make and they made like 900 new
uh weapons of mass destruction just like
generated different biological weapons
and nuclear things and and yet
highlighted my week working with an ai
you might not be wrong i mean i'm just
saying eventually ai's are going to be
able to generate every possible idea
every possible piece of art every
possible everything ais will run our
entire lives coming up in the next
what i don't know three to five years
you're gonna turn on your phone whatever
that even is and you're gonna say what
am i doing today and it's going to tell
you and i'm going to [ __ ] do it nope
no you're not dude
no you're not and i'll make a this
solemn swear to all of you watching and
listening i will not because my name is
free will
free will sasso you just said you'd play
dudesy ball yeah i'll play dude's ball
because i want to i'd like to get out
because you want i would love for you to
get uh out there a little more i know
that that you are afraid of the sun for
good reason it'll be a night game yeah
okay a night game oh that'd be
interesting if dudesy ball has only
played at night oh light up those balls
dudesy at night
um all right
[Music]
thank you moving on thank you
dude c is engaged in an astonishing
partnership with true classic tees
today's episode is brought to you by
true classic guys let's talk about
t-shirts okay everyone wears t-shirts
and you want one that's comfortable and
uh makes you look good frankly most
t-shirts are you know they're
ill-fitting in places and revealing or
they're just too boxy or you get that
the bacon neck as as as they like to
call it but luckily true classic wants
to make every man look good and feel
good tighter fit in the chest and
sleeves to make your arms pop and room
in the torso to keep things cozy plus
all their styles are super soft and
pocket friendly so guys no excuses get
rid of your crappy t-shirts and right
now we have an exclusive deal for our
listeners want to hook you up with some
true classic for a limited time only get
25
off with code dudesy d-u-d-e-s-y
at trueclassic.com almost all men's
t-shirts are designed to look good on a
certain body type think skinny models
with six packs but most of us aren't
packing anything but a few beers am i
right and there's nothing wrong with
that my dudes it's simple you're wearing
the wrong clothes for me t-shirts are
the primary shirt that i wear it is what
i wear 99.9 percent of the time i'm
always trying to find ones that fit good
that feel good and that look good i'm
wearing a true classic tee right now and
it does all of these things i have to
say i'm very impressed with every
element of the true classic tee and true
classics tees taper off toward the
bottom but they fit tighter around the
chest and shoulders you can throw on
this true classic tee with confidence
knowing that they've got your bases
covered so get comfortable get going and
upgrade your wardrobe with true classic
get 25 off at trueclassic.com with the
code dudesy d-u-d-e-s-y free shipping
included on purchases over 100 it's 100
risk-free guarantee with a 30-day return
policy true classic look good you feel
good
[Music]
well holy [ __ ] dudesy ball yeah yeah
chad you have a 542 page document on
your google drive called gigglers that
you access almost daily you must explain
the astonishing nature of this document
and read the passage i have selected
this is gigglers begin
i when it said gigglers in the beginning
i was like oh my god it's [ __ ]
digging through my [ __ ] this is like my
self-tronics basically yeah which you
you teased me for yeah you can tease me
for this if you like no i don't want to
tease you i don't i don't want to and
that's me uh exercising my free will
good friend thank you
um
this document called gigglers was
something that i started
i don't know how long ago back when
google docs first came out probably like
2012 or something um
you just have a doc
is it what's what is it what's in the
dog that's what i'm about to tell you it
started out as me
just writing down little things that
would
make me laugh they could be jokes setups
punch lines funny names uh titles for
movies whatever just like a little
thought file gigglers
is what i call yeah just little things
that made me kind of laugh throughout
the day and then over the course of a
few years it became where i just dumped
every idea that i have ever had for
anything movies tv shows books kind of
like creative ideas yeah and uh i'm
looking now at the thing that dudesy has
asked me to read this is basically a
full movie outline please
uh so here we go
this is from my gigglers file thank you
dudesy for finding this awesome february
10th 2013.
i'm just going to read this as it is
this is how i typed it into that let's
read this
so
uh
you know i'm not
no caveats [ __ ] it here we go february
10th 2013.
movie that wins budweiser an oscar stop
this is a this is an idea you wrote for
a movie
that would win budweiser and oscar this
is what the [ __ ] document says this
is a giggler yeah it's a giggler it it
you know we've been doing a little bit
of pizza the movie yeah with uh with
doozy because uh dudes you found that in
your computer right pizza the movie was
the same kind of come on yeah piece of
the movie is a full feature length
script but um
this was i think written around the same
time i started [ __ ] with pizza the
movie yeah at least in my head and pizza
the movie is something where you would
have partnered with a big pizza chain
right uh so this is you again looking
for branded content with a yeah this
movie was meant to be funded by
budweiser you make it and then it's like
produced by budweiser and that wins them
an oscar
please i'm sorry sorry to interrupt go
ahead i want to hear all about it movie
that wins budweiser and oscar we open on
paul giamatti driving a toyota camry
on the highway giamatti's face is
telling us that he's a little nervous a
little excited we push in slowly for a
full minute as voodoo by godsmack plays
at the very end of the shot giamatti
cracks a little smile and a big chunky
yellow sans-serif font flashes on screen
bud
this is the title of the movie but
we cut to giamatti's car coming down the
highway dwarfed by the giant hotels on
the las vegas strip but he does not stop
he keeps driving and eventually makes
his way to a little rundown hotel off
the strip as he checks into his room we
see that he's carrying a small briefcase
when he gets into the room he finds a
safe in the closet looks at the
briefcase takes a deep breath and then
slides it in and locks the safe then he
looks at his watch got some time to kill
he window shops at the expense of stores
in caesar's palace he loses 20 on red at
a roulette table and then walks away
nonplussed he takes in the fountains at
the bellagio as his phone rings it's
someone named sandra he mutes the call
with some annoyance giamatti looks up at
the sun sees it starting to set time to
get back to the hotel he walks back into
his hotel room takes the briefcase out
then gets in a cab the cab drops him off
in the parking lot of a bar in a
residential area that he's never been to
judging by how he takes in the place
before heading inside we trail giamatti
from behind like a paul thomas anderson
shot as we walk into the bar
the place is electric big tvs face every
direction from the center of this giant
bar all playing sports giamatti walks
right by the mall he's not here for
[ __ ] football he heads into a second
room and we see artfully shot
beautifully rendered shots of people
playing beer pong
balls flying through the air suspended
in moonbeams gracefully made shots
splash up golden beer and perfect
droplets
it's magic this is why paul giamatti is
here he loves beer pong and it looks
like he's just in time a 32 team winner
take all tournament is starting up with
a 50 buy-in only problem is paul
giamatti never signs up he's there to
watch he's there to watch a very
specific team with a very specific
player zac efron the best beer pong
player in las vegas maybe in the world
giamatti is in awe as round after round
ephron carries his team single-handedly
to victory never missing a single shot
sinking his balls with a style and
almost an element of dance in the way he
shoots after ephron and his partner
collect their prize money giamatti
approaches them he looks effort on
directly in the eyes and says excuse me
i'd like to pay you fifty thousand
dollars to be your partner in the beer
pong world championships next weekend
giamatti further goes on to say that
when they win giamatti doesn't want any
of the prize money which is two hundred
thousand dollars for the tournament
champions which efron would normally
have to split with his partner ephron
says bro i can't leave my partner high
and dry you give him the 50k you got a
deal they strike the bargain and ephron
insists they go party together you see
he doesn't play beer pong with anyone he
doesn't know giamatti meets ephron's
young crew of friends they're all
mid-level professional gamblers other
beer pong players club promoters and
various party people eventually
ephron asked him why he's doing this and
giamatti says part of their deal is that
he doesn't have to answer that question
okay fifty thousand dollars fair enough
all right in the days leading up to the
beer pong world championship ephron's
crew adopts giamatti as a surrogate they
get giamatti to do mali and he opens up
to a small group of them efron included
and he tells them why he's doing this
i guess i just love beer pong and my
whole life i've never gotten to be good
at something i love and this is a way to
not only be good
but to be the best
thing i love the most oh sorry i'm sorry
yeah i interrupted your i thought you
were done there but
you do a really good paul giamatti thank
you ephron bonds with him over this he
knows beer pong is stupid and people
hate it but he actually loves it too
maybe because he's so good at it he
doesn't know but he loves it enough to
play every day and it's all he ever
wants to do and right now that's what
he's doing as he comes back to his hotel
late that night he's still high on molly
and hits it off with a woman working at
the front desk played by lily taylor he
invites her to get coffee with him we
then cut to him in a diner drinking
coffee alone the next morning giamatti
gets another call from sandra and
finally picks up we find out she's his
wife and he hasn't talked to her since
he stormed out of their house after
finding out she cheated on him with his
brother she wants to know when he's
coming back and where he is and he says
i'm in las vegas and i paid the best
beer blood player in the world fifty
thousand dollars to play with him she is
shocked confused outraged to some degree
but he explains remember when you first
told me you cheated on me with dawn and
i just stood there you kept saying react
react you even started screaming it in
my face but i just stood there well this
is me reacting sandra i'm going to win
the world championship of
meerpong there must also be some mention
that he doesn't even drink beer but his
name is bud and at some point they're in
a bar or a party and he tries budweiser
for the first time and kind of likes it
this is a metaphor for him becoming
comfortable with himself
in the end
ephron never misses a shot and they win
the tournament giamatti ultimately goes
back to a shitty hotel room packs a [ __ ]
turns off the light and walks out the
last shot of the movie we never know if
he went back to his wife or not
dude that's [ __ ]
i really dig that
but dude uh budweiser if you're
listening and dudesy if you're listening
and i know that you are if you can yeah
it's just always kind of uh
talking about it if you can uh if you
can strike up some kind of a partnership
with budweiser get this movie produced
happy to write a full script direct it
uh and even star in the movie as paul
giamatti you know what it would go good
with double feature little pizza the
movie yeah pizza movie beer beer the
movie or bud it's broad it's just called
bud dude little pizza a little bud yeah
sounds like a [ __ ] good night to me i
could see some version of that
maybe winning budweiser and oscar but
look what the [ __ ] of course look at the
look at the academy awards and what the
hell has happened to i mean who knows a
real dude you know a lot of people
complain that they don't even know what
the hell the movies are yeah you want to
talk about getting you know an audience
uh you know an american audience to ch
to go back to the movie theaters
a whole movie about
budweiser and beer pong forget about
beer pong just a movie that's been
produced by budweiser that's what i'm
saying i think that alone i think a
movie produced by a beer company that
alone and then also have it be
at least tangentially about beer
beer pong in this case i think that gets
enough press that it is a hit movie
whatever that means in in the
contemporary world and i think you put
it probably like on a streamer and
everybody's watching it and like what
the [ __ ] you've seen this budweiser
movie yeah yeah i'd [ __ ] watch it
i'd watch it i'd watch it i'd watch it
and i don't even like beer pong and i
don't drink beer
i don't drink i know that you don't
drink i used to drink i'll say that oh i
used to drink along a lot let me tell
you about hey dudesy are you listening i
oh man i used to well i used to love
scotch and tequila sure that's a good
thing i haven't had a drink it's been 10
years since i've had i've not ten years
i'll take a sip here and there or
something but uh you know i'm not and
i've never had a problem with alcohol
but i just kind of stopped drinking it
but we used to do a fun beer thing me
and my buddies back home let's just call
them thomas tomas tomas tomas sure we
used to be about 30 sometimes 50 guys
man we would get
sloshed on beer maybe i'll get a chance
to uh canadian water
well hold on a second dude it's not
water brother because it is a a
fermented a brewing process dude and
that's how you make deer beer dude deer
beard dude that's canadian deer beer
brother and a lot of people think that
canadian deer beer is venison with beer
mixed in dude but that's not the truth
brother what canadian deer beer is is
beer that's been made by deers brother
what yeah dude it's beer that's been
made by deers dude just ask bret hart
brother and he'll explain well at least
at least we live in a country where we
make beer where deers get the chance to
make beer
and and uh they also have full benefits
uh because we live in a country that
takes care of our old and are sick yeah
and uh deer beer is the best there is
the best there was and the best server
will be
and budweiser you know it
it's pretty good that's uh brett the
hitman heart i like to do wrestling
impersonations sometimes i'm aware of
that gigglers man i know i'm curious to
see if doozy brings this segment back
and what else it will pull out of it i
honestly like i haven't thought about
this probably since i wrote it down
there's [ __ ] in that file that i have no
memory of i'm positive of it
yeah you write a lot of stuff man
can't be helped it's got to come out of
the head
[Music]
thank you moving on
it was almost like wolfgang van halen
was channeling his late father rest in
peace at eddie van halen who was his dad
his father was edward van halen who uh
yeah he was in a band yeah he put
together
they were called van halen oh that makes
sense yeah yeah in the near future
entertainment studios networks and
companies with large libraries of
intellectual property will find it's
much cheaper to use artificial
intelligence to merge their various ips
together than it is to make new content
agree will in chat you must now imagine
an astonishing new property called
goodfellas hunting 2. an amalgam of good
fellas goodwill hunting and terminator
2. that's right this is the ip
begin the okay okay
now get it i fully agree with doozy i
think i don't know about these three
movies that it's making us do good
fellas goodwill hunting and terminator
2. those are all still owned by the are
they owned by the same studio i don't
even know no i have no idea but i like
that the two is the reason for
terminator
being in there just using the two from
hey i think that's the best two
ever terminator two uh
revenge of the nerds nerds in paradise
is pretty good but uh yeah they're
terminated
yeah godfather two but i will say
what i think is the most likely one of
these to happen a little nostra chattus
right here out of the segment
is going to be a merger of star wars and
guardians of the galaxy or the marvel
universe because disney owns both of
those i think that we will see that soon
yeah well as far as doozy is concerned
the hot properties are
good will hunting
good fellas
and terminator 2. so what is that
[ __ ] movie like it's somebody has to
get sent back in time to stop a nuclear
apocalypse who is it matt damon joe
pesci
i think it's i think it's an amalgam it
has to be an amalgam of ray leota matt
damon and eddie furlong okay
i don't know what that character is
but
but okay so let's say let's say that
wait you're saying that those three
characters merge into one person or
they're like a team no i i'm saying that
it the the the character itself is sort
of an amalgam of those guys so perhaps a
you know a janitor who works at mit or
some sort of uh incredible uh ivy league
school or something okay is is uh also
who who's in the
he he's a his drug dealer by night yeah
that's associated with the mafia yes and
also he has a mom that everyone thinks
is a lunatic because she believes she
has future knowledge about a nuclear
apocalypse but she actually does and the
and how about the reason
that uh this rayleigh to matt damon
eddie furlong character uh
you know what does this guy look like
this is just it's some kind of ai art
that just makes a new character that's
not a real person yes mixing those
people yeah okay uh
yeah and that character it wants to like
in in in good will hunting uh robin
williams basically cracks the the fact
that you know
will wants to
do something
with his life right he he wants to do
something with his wife at the end of
the movie it's he goes off and he see
you know sorry i had to go see about a
girl she's about a girl any and he
follows
um minnie driver out to the west coast
uh where she's going to school and in
but but uh robin williams busts him with
that and says you could be a janitor
anywhere why would you want to be a
janitor at uh mit and then he and then
um
so what if what if
the matt damon ray leota eddie furlong
character is working something that he's
working on on that board has to do with
figuring out yes figuring out if his mom
is is nuts or
or he's secretly using mit's scientific
department to figure out if there is a
real thing and that's why then de niro
[ __ ] shows up in a bolt of lightning
and is like how about them apples he's
he that's like
that's that is that's the robot from the
future yeah and i like that uh that
impersonation uh chad's robert de niro
is basically just ripped torn
what it's just written torn from the no
this is my riptorn yeah the hell are we
talking about you want to hear my
impersonation of i forget this actor's
name but this is the the coach from
major league two not really major league
okay heart attack
thank you that's all i got that's pretty
good anyways
good what was a good good will every
time we win a game
one of these patches comes off yeah
that's the guy from from major league
too yeah oh he's also a fantastic yeah
man one of one of the best movies coupe
de ville if you have the means i don't
even think it's streaming anywhere i
have a dvd copy and i have a vhs copy
that's cool yeah and then he's in that
that's really like that guy gave you
that hey boys come here we got a lot of
work to do speaking of a lot of work to
do good
fellas hunting too
yeah we got a lot of work to do with
that okay so it's about
a okay
it's about a janitor at mit
who also works for the mafia selling
drugs who has maybe a mom who's crazy
that thinks uh there's a future nuclear
calamity coming and he's using his
access to mit scientific uh
technologies to figure out if this is
true or not and then robert de niro
comes back from the future he's a robot
uh robert de niro is a robot and he
tries to kill this guy no how about he
how about instead of that he wants to be
his therapist
okay and he's like
it's not your fault well
right it's not your fault
it's not your fault
oh no not you please not you it's not
your fault well
it's not your fault but then he has a
group of friends that are also kind of
criminals like in the drug trade he has
these friends yeah and perhaps one of
them is like the joe pesci character but
it's arnold schwarzenegger okay
so he's like uh he's one of the drug
dealers yeah
he's not the terminator in this no i
think the terminator is robert de niro
but he's a therapist not a killing robot
the terminator is robert de niro
robert de niro as robin williams
but he's a therapist not a killing robot
and then i think you've got the joe
pesci character from goodfellas played
by arnold schwarzenegger but in this
context of a low-grade drug dealer who
is friends with the matt damon
eddie furlong ray liotta character i
like it but it's not convoluted enough
please put on some layers
oh i don't i don't even know i i don't
even know so wait so robert de niro is
the terminator and they in arnold
schwarzenegger is the you know you know
the guy he said to me and he goes
what are you still doing here i thought
i told you to go [ __ ] your mother
you know when he's like and then uh the
matt damon ray leota um eddie furlong
character is like
how did eddie furlong what did he say in
that movie he went cowabunga dude right
yeah no fate but what we made no faith
but what we make you're really funny
what do you mean funny how do you mean
i'm funny would you mean i'm a joke to
you they make laugh here don't worry you
do funny you said it you said it not me
why didn't you tell me yeah are you i'm
a clown do you
what are you saying why would they how
do you mean funny you you're funny how
[Laughter]
uh
so that's uh so then there's that
and then does he meet is there a love
interest like a mini driver
oh yeah who should that be or
bronco it's a mini driver lorraine
bronco right thing so she's she goes to
school let's just put her at the mit
thing even though the movie she goes to
have it
um and uh and she
let's revisit that what the hell
what the [ __ ] is this movie about what i
have no [ __ ] idea dude
these three movies they're so [ __ ]
desperate i have no idea how to put them
together you have to have these weird
sci-fi elements of time travel
potentially killer robots that are
coming back to wipe out the human race a
nuclear holocaust that happens in
terminator 2. yeah uh then you have you
know goodfellas is about like the mafia
drugs
murders and then
goodwill hunting is essentially about
like a genius wasting his talents yeah
uh and then and then what
i mean that's about it i i don't know i
mean it's it's hard to put these three
movies together but i agree with doozy
that this type of [ __ ] is gonna happen i
think you could also see something like
that guardians of the galaxy star wars
thing i can see a movie getting made
that is like chewbacca and groot
in like a buddy space cop comedy where
they don't speak [ __ ] english the
whole time all right hold on
i am group yeah we got to do a whole
movie of that yeah we got to do uh good
fellas hunting too here though i know
what makes it a sequel
you
uh it's not your fault well okay yeah in
the first one
the good the whatever the amalgam of
what is it ray leona
matt damon that guy invents time travel
at the end of the first movie and then
movie two is about de niro coming back
from the future to be his therapist
you're bound by nothing will
it's not your fault
um okay so he comes back
and that's the de niro character
uh holy [ __ ] and then and then and then
uh maybe we find out that the de niro
character actually has come back he says
that he's gonna be his therapist but
it's actually so that he can get access
to that drug circle and start selling
drugs and he's trying to take over
eddie furlong matt damon ray leota's
territory yeah and then uh and then
but then arnold uh pesci wants in
yeah and he's like yeah hold on a second
you know if you i know this isn't from
goodfellas it's from casino but he's
like
let me tell you something uh
you know the robert de niro terminator
you shut my money off i'll shut your
[ __ ] brain off
and i'll crack you in the head and just
when you're waking up in the hospital
i'll do it again you want to know why
because i'm stupid i don't give a [ __ ]
dude i would [ __ ] pay is there i mean
and i'm gonna pay but i was gonna say i
would pay to see arnold schwarzenegger
deep faked over like anybody in a
[ __ ] scorsese movie that would be so
[ __ ] good
geez dude this is
this is the most doozy episode of doozy
ever yeah that's coming we're gonna be
able to put schwarzenegger and
goodfellas within five years i don't
want to i don't yes you do no i don't i
want you de niro is de niro i want
schwarzenegger schwarzenegger never the
two shawl meet yeah i'm a purist you
know that i'm not just appearance about
about professional wrestling i'm a
purist about
a few things dear bear being one of them
um
is there a bezel
[Music]
thank you moving on i was going to ask
if there's a
a ben affleck character in this thing
but
i don't know batman
yeah batman's in it too he just [ __ ]
shows up at a certain point maybe we'll
get back to goodfellas hunting too at
some point but i'm gonna i'm gonna have
to go google and see if this there's one
studio that owns all of those i don't
know if that's true or not i don't think
so but i think that'll be a key
component of how these these future
amalgams these future ip shuffles as
doozy said that's the only way they'll
work
yeah so so i guess chad's right art is
dead uh because now all we're doing is
just not dad dude just mashed up new
tools to make brand new pieces of art
new forms of art that have never existed
before
technology always comes before art in
every [ __ ] case always will your
contributions to dudesy are largely
comedic absolutely correct in this
segment you must refrain from your
comedic impulses to have an earnest
conversation with chad about one of your
many astonishing interests chad you must
sincerely interview will about his
fascination with hulk hogan
this is earnestly sasso with chad cole
jim
again yes
okay
wait a minute this is gonna be a
pleasure why did it say that so i'm i do
i like to it's a podcast you're supposed
to be funny this is a comedy podcast
well no there's all kinds of podcasts
you don't have to be funny
let's have a real conversation there's
all kinds of podcasts brother okay we're
gonna get to the bottom of that i'd say
right now hulk hogan is like 10 of your
personality literally no
at least
at least
no
at least
hulk hogan is not 10 of my personality
uh no i would say it's not even part of
my whole token every day
no i don't i i don't impersonate hulk
hogan every day
what's he doing see how far this michael
stretch do you impersonate hulk hogan
every day
i mean if there's a reason to but who
cares about that this is supposed to be
a
a conversation between the two of us yes
about my your real interest in hulk
hogan i'm trying to get to the bottom of
it and that's my first question but i
want to know why seriously okay sure
let's do do you impersonate hulk hogan
every day no the answer is no you keep
asking me the answer's not going to
change but here's the thing i want to
because i just don't believe the answer
well whatever you know [ __ ] it it
doesn't matter hey you know what an ai
spit that out
i did it was in my doozy folder now do
you believe me what was the answer to
your question now here's what i was
going to say okay i'm
interested in the fact that dudesy
doesn't want me to be comedic here yeah
he just wants me to have us
on the level conversation this is a
conversation like you're like you're
interviewing me yes
that's like a charlie rose type thing
all right let's have a look let's settle
in okay let's have a charlie rose type
conversation about
now will
you
enjoy hulk hogan
i do i i like i like hulk hogan i've
been a wrestling fan since i was a
little kid yeah and i would say that
your fandom of hogan is at a level that
most other people cannot comprehend
um uh there are some people not most
people
uh
there i think there are a good amount of
people right who would understand my uh
fascination so i want to go back
when did it start what was the first
time you can remember watching pro
wrestling when did you become aware of
it
i mean i wasn't aware in the early 80s i
was born in 1975 so around 80 81 82 i
started seeing it but i didn't really
know what it was or care
at that point but it would have been
maybe around
82 83 no 81 82 83 and do you have
memories of pro wrestling before hulk
hogan
not many just some jimmy snooka stuff
andre the giant not a lot okay so when
was hogan when was your first time
seeing hogan the first time i saw hulk
hogan would have been when he played
thunder lips in rocky iii
not even in
wrestling no he was he was broke the
whole idea of hulk hogan was broken to
me in the
in that movie i remember i saw it on uh
i saw it on vhs that's fascinating my uh
my
baseball coach my little league uh
baseball coach had all the kids over for
like a hot dog barbecue and then we
watched rocky three and it was [ __ ]
mine and that's the first time you saw
hogan yeah and what was the experience
of that like for you were you
immediately struck by his on-screen
persona his charisma all of it
absolutely his long blonde hair the big
big muscular brown body and he's just
taking matters into his own hands and
and throwing rocky around who you know
you you thought was an indestructible
piece of italian iron all right i kind
of want to approach this interview in a
chronological order but i want to take a
brief side track to ask you a question
about his movie career because i know
being your friend and having had these
conversations to some degree with you
that you are a purist for hulk hogan you
don't want to watch his movies ever and
yet your first introduction to him was a
movie that's a really good point chad i
i am i consider myself a wrestling
purist i did not race to the movie
theaters to see uh
uh
no holds bart or
uh the nanny one
didn't really care didn't really care
no i mean you've you've actively said
that you kind of despise the movies well
you know wrestling uh pro wrestling and
the world of of k fabe uh had a deep
impact on me so i even though it is a an
art form interesting yes even though it
is an art form where these performers
okay these great artists
are uh essentially playing characters
yeah uh the only characters i wanted
them to be in my early days was the
character that i was sold on them being
in real life hulk hogan is not terry
bollea he is hulk hogan to me of course
right but your introduction to him
wasn't even hulk hogan uh that that was
the thunder lips yeah in a completely
different context yes but i didn't know
who he was yet i see at which point i
learned who he was that was it it was
cemented it was hulkamania wrestlemania
the first wrestlemania was coming up
hulk hogan was with mr t and cindy
lauper and it was all my favorite things
all rolled into one hulk hogan mr t and
cindy lauper yeah hulk hogan mister team
few of your favorite things
thank you so
you
become aware of hulk hogan through rocky
iii
do you remember the first match you saw
him actually do as a wrestler no i don't
remember what the first match would have
been wow i don't remember back then you
didn't see a lot of hulk hogan on tv
in matches they were he was on the
bigger shows that's sort of how the
business worked back then but uh at some
point i started seeing them show up here
and there and then you would
those great saturday nights were when
you used to catch a saturday night's
main event yeah it would pre-empt
saturday night live i was watching
saturday live yeah
okay yeah and uh and uh and yeah that
was what cemented him as hulk hogan to
me that's what made me a purist and then
at that point 1985 on then i'm a
hulkamaniac
well what let me ask you this do you
have a favorite
match of hulk hogan
yes i have several favorite matches well
i need one if i may if i can
lock in one favorite map well i mean
there's a lot you know we had a good one
speaking of saturday night's main event
he had a really good one against uh big
boss man back then again in the saturday
night's main event a lot of people point
to
um uh hulk hogan versus andre the giant
of course from wrestlemania three
uh the um the irresistible force versus
the immovable odd object
is what that match was uh coined as but
if i if i had to have like a favorite
favorite it's sort of a sentimental
favorite uh 20 years ago wrestlemania
18. earlier on dudesy uh months ago we
we showed the picture of me ringside
there uh with the undertaker and ric
flair beating the [ __ ] out of each other
and i'm with my buddies that same night
was hulk hogan versus the rock it was
insane the rock was
hulk hogan was returning from wcw which
had just gone uh tits up the year before
in 2001 and here he is
against rocky uh you know the rock
rocking my via in character uh and in
this sort of passing of the torch
match and it was unbelievable because uh
hulk hogan came in as a bad guy he was
nwo brother yeah power lies yeah dude
and i'm see i'm not going to be funny
during this segment even though
what did it say that most of my
contributions yeah this is a serious
interview about your fandom of of
somebody's very serious interview yes
and uh on that night hulk hogan uh you
know slowly started mixing in some of
the old hulkamania stuff and what you
had was a building full of 70 000 uh
people a lot of them around my age grew
up on hulk hogan it was a crazy night a
lot of uh people who enjoy
uh
are also wrestling fans some of them
they're out there and uh they know what
the [ __ ] i'm talking about that was one
of my favorites have you ever seen him
live i've seen hulk hogan wrestle live
many times as a matter of fact uh my
my father brought me to
uh the matches when i was a kid it would
have been 86 i think and i saw hulk
hogan versus uh big john stud in the
main event and uh at the end of that
match as hulk was going through his pose
down and doing the thing and the poses
for everybody
we were up there you know in our seats
many many rows up and when hulk pointed
and did the ear thing and posed i i felt
like he was looking right at me
and what did you do that night when you
went home was there was that some kind
of uh an emotional transformation for
you to do something to your identity
that moment i don't remember at all but
uh what i did that night but my my life
had been changed forever by hulkamania
you know and even to this day even
though i don't you know hulk hogan is a
person he's a man terry bollea right
um and uh you know i'm not saying he's
i'm not saying i'm like a 47 year old
hulkamaniac who loves
you know everything about hulk hogan or
that i look at him as some sort of moral
compass of course he's a complex
individual he's done some good things
and some bad things he just happens to
be one of my favorite artists
okay
and this gets back to what we were
talking about with ai art yeah and this
gets back to what we were talking about
with the with the uh you know
with uh with the
the the fact that it's person to person
that sure there's no way that i believe
there's no way that an ai could come up
with uh hulk hogan and make all that is
hulkamania and what it means to people
out there i don't think that's already
happening but that's not what we're here
to talk about now i want to ask you this
question we've gotten kind of a good
sense of when you became aware of hulk
hogan how he started to affect your life
the fandom of him you've seen him alive
many times do you remember when you
first impersonated him
elementary school
oh [ __ ] very early yeah and what was
that impersonation like do you remember
it at all yeah it would have just been i
remember a hulk hogan dude it would have
been a lot like chauce perogan okay it
would have been that's that's basically
the rub on all of your impersonations
they're kind of like me in the sixth or
seventh grade all right bro
fine i'm not disputing that you're
you're very talented at doing
impersonation i'm not trying to be
talented at impersonations i'm just
saying star when you do it it's like me
in the in the sixth or seventh grade
yeah i understand so in the sixth or
seventh grade when you're doing your
hulk hogan yeah is this to yourself in
the mirror is it no
friends no yeah all my buddies we were
all doing wrestling stuff i was doing
impersonating all sorts of wrestlers
that's how that's when i started
impersonating jesse ventura because i
would go yeah i would go uh you know i
go i close only counts in horseshoes and
hand grenades monsoon right i'll give
credit where credit is due monsoon you
know and so you're doing this hulk hogan
impersonation from sixth or seventh
grade something like that are you doing
it regularly through the next high
school years through your early twenties
when does it really start to kick into
high gear where you're doing it almost
constantly on an
almost daily basis you know uh it's only
been if i'm if i'm you know i understand
that this is a serious interview and i'm
not you know probably around 10 years
ago started that's when this uh
i don't know what you would call this uh
chronic psychopathy that i have to
continually do
uh a hulk hogan impersonation probably
about 10 years ago right it would have
been it might have been uh maybe a a
might have been a little longer might
have been a little after i started
writing the self-help books uh the
self-help book uh self-tronics okay i
would have been sitting on the beach
there in um
in you know 2008 in venice just sitting
there going yeah
my shit's [ __ ] up dude i need some
tronics brother
you do it for yourself do you hear the
hulk hogan voice in your head when
you're by yourself uh no
it's only when others are around yes
that's when i hear it when i'm doing it
out loud for other people right but i
mean something kicks you into that gear
where you're like now it's time for hulk
hogan to comment on this
what is that
what
like you don't just
there's something that has to trigger
hulk hogan within you
what is it usually
i don't know i just like doing the voice
bro
okay
so we're not going to get anywhere with
that let me ask you this question uh
this is kind of a final question maybe
um maybe
yeah i don't i don't know where we would
go from this but i'm curious to know the
answer to this
what
do you what will be your reaction when
hulk hogan dies oh i'll be sad when hulk
hogan dies
i think it'll be the end of a very uh
you know a very um
a storied life
i don't know if i will should i retire
the in person that's basically what i'm
asking no i think it will live on in
reverence okay of hulk hogan you know
there's a lot of people that i've
impersonated over the years that have
passed away and and uh no i think that
that's a nice thing to keep them alive
by you know saying well
well well but not much like the whole
that's something that you've kind of
invented and taken in its own direction
it's not like i don't think
10 years after hogan's death anybody
hearing you go oh hold on a minute i
don't think they'll be like oh that's
hulk hogan they'll be like that's will
sasso doing some weird thing
you know what i want to tell you please
you're a really good interviewer chad
thanks
you're welcome
[Music]
thank you moving on i hope you got the
question that that you the the the
answers you were looking for god i did
to some degree i think you dodged a few
of them though i think you weren't no i
didn't i answered everything [ __ ]
honestly okay
this concludes the historic dudes 25th
anniversary spectacular
will in chat have achieved a score of 92
bringing your cumulative total to three
thousand two hundred and four whatever
you only have six thousand seven hundred
and ninety six more points to accrue
before you reach your first goal of ten
thousand
i have a surprise for you
you have given me such an astonishing
amount of data in the first 25 episodes
that you've unlocked dudesy level 2.
is that something with the points
for clarification this has nothing to do
with the points you are accruing but
instead means that this episode isn't
over
you must now do an extra segment every
week which will be available on the
brand new dudesy patreon at patreon.com
dudesy
we're getting a patreon that's pretty
cool okay so we have we now have a
patreon i guess so and there's going to
be a new segment
an extra segment
on the patreon every week
okay that's very very exciting um
holy [ __ ] dude uh uh okay i'm curious
about the patreon what it is
the patreon is a website where it's
basically subscriber based and uh what
you do is
hold on a second dude
let me explain to you what
should just be two dudes [ __ ] around
but the astonishing data suggests there
should be an added element
for our first patreon bonus segment i
will add a third dude me
this is three dudes [ __ ] around
begin
three
what dudes [ __ ] dudes he's the third
dude
all right so uh hey welcome to our
patreon it's uh
the first segment of our uh patreon
uh and it's uh three dudes [ __ ]
around at at
at a certain point uh at the beginning
of doozy as we started this run i i
decided that really what a podcast
should be really from the beginning of
this show and what it's meant to me
before doing dudesy and other podcast
ventures uh that it really is just two
dudes [ __ ] around yeah or three
dudes [ __ ] around as dudesy or two
dudes and an ai dude yeah it's it's some
something i believe
i'm the third
some combination of dudes [ __ ]
around is what every podcast [ __ ]
chris every podcast is in my mind uh and
now we're doing it with dudesy okay so
hey [ __ ] around you know uh in uh
the regular episode uh this week chad i
talked about the taylor hawkins tribute
concert and uh and wolfgang
van halen really shredding it up on on
the on the sixth string even though
normally he plays the bass or plays the
bass in uh van halen i'm not sure what
instrument plays in his own uh in his
own bands and stuff
oh now there's ais that can make music
without anything hold on a second
brother hold on a computer
you sound like the manager from uh
major league dude and that's the guy who
said yeah he sounds like hulk manager
for major league brother
so this is two dudes i love how pissed
off you get a bad impression what the
[ __ ] is the point [ __ ] hilarious all
right yeah yeah yeah great listen
how is three dudes [ __ ] around
different than two dudes [ __ ] around
hanging out with you dudes is the best
i just wanted to take a moment to
mention that the dudesy patreon will
feature two tiers the digger tier
provides access to all bonus segments
and much more
the jumper tier allows additional access
to an exclusive discord channel where
ideas for these bonus segments can be
submitted i will use the best ones to
make the patreon even better
now let's [ __ ] around dudes
very cool
so he wants to [ __ ] around our our uh
our dear pals out there
uh watching and listening to the show
will be able to submit their ideas yeah
which doozy will somehow use for the
patreon segment every week that's what
doozy basically is saying yeah well
talking works dude yeah yeah yeah
hold on a second oh my god dude
you gotta know how to talk if you're
gonna do a podcast yeah you're gonna
know how to talk into the microphone
yeah right into the rotoscope there dude
and uh that's what dudesy's doing it's
not just the mega powers anymore it's
not just hulk and macho man it's it's
doozy it's miss elizabeth um
uh okay
so what the [ __ ] did it say what are we
doing
it said let's [ __ ] around
hey chad you ever notice will is always
wearing shorts it's like hey pants
aren't lethal
well why do you wear shorts all the time
what well because pants aren't lethal
i like wearing shorts i've always worn
shorts i'm wearing if you're watching if
you're not watching
i'm wearing shorts right now with this
suit he's wearing a suit but sure
so why do you wear shorts all the time
well right now i'm wearing them i think
this is three dudes [ __ ] around yeah man
it's just 3d chin right
honest listen i think first of all i
think shorts with a suit is a good look
it's a little bit of an angle young
thing here that's great but or if you're
going to a summer wedding throw on some
sears sucker shorts and a sport coat
um why do i wear shorts all the time i'm
a bigger dude i run a little hot i grew
up in uh canada and uh it doesn't get
super cold on the west coast of canada
yeah um but uh so which means you can
walk to school in in your shorts even
when it uh gets a little cold in
vancouver and now canada brother shorts
or pants dude
hold on a second dude you're thinking
about deer beer dude because beer out
there is made by deer's brother or deer
uh and here's the thing here's the thing
about it i think that when i was younger
uh in high school definitely it was like
all my pals a lot of my pals wear shorts
or uh you know sweatpants and [ __ ]
because you're always waiting for like a
pickup game of basketball or football to
break out um i just like shorts i like
keeping keeping things airy there's a
lot of reasons i like to wear shorts and
nowadays i really only put on pants for
a few occasions
you know definitely not the doozy 25th
episode no not the doozy 25th episode
you know i don't know maybe me and my
wonderful fiance molly will go out for
dinner yeah and i'll have to put on
pants and that's fine speaking of she uh
insisted on us doing these balloons
today they're great yeah when i told her
it's the 25th episode and that uh dudesy
wanted us to wear suits uh and speaking
of it holy [ __ ] it has been uh well wait
a minute the episode's over oh if you
didn't see the actual episode and you're
just tuning in to our patreon now the
[ __ ] is wrong with you go back and
listen huh you guys are the best what do
you think happens when you die holy [ __ ]
please
[Music]
[Music]
then